6 says las vegas reopens alex the next
challenge
for all the resorts really is to try and
hire workers back
yeah circa is looking to fill dozens of
positions as tourists return
hector mejia live downtown with the
details hey hector this is great news
it really is it's a positive sign you
know people looking for
jobs if you're looking for a job a lot
of people are this is one place circa
looking to hire as many as a hundred
people and i should note that you should
be prepared
for interviews on the spot so it's all
happening here at golden gate casino
here at the valley area so you'll pull
in from main street and go down below
all the way to the end where you see
that hiring event banner
now staff right now they're working to
bring out some tables but this all
starts pretty soon
it starts at nine o'clock this morning
and going on until one o'clock in the
afternoon
again about a hundred positions up for
grabs and they're all inside circa the
brand new casino a lot of people have
been talking about
so if you're wondering which positions
are in top demand those are
housekeepers and security however
you have to be 21 and over for those
positions
they have others for younger people for
those who are 18 and over
that is for the guest room attendant
position those are open
too now you don't need to pre-register
you can just drive up or you can also
walk up
but you'll have to fill out an
application at some point either before
you get here or after you leave
so here are a few tips from staff here
dress to impress
bring a resume if you have one and also
they'll have bilingual staff
available in case anyone has any
language barriers and again
this starts at nine o'clock this morning
one more thing before i let you guys go
if you're not able to make it down here
today they have another hiring event
happening two weeks from today that is
happening on april 27th
and the concept will also be a
drive-through style so if you remember
just last year we were talking about
coronavirus testing as a drive through
it now
we're talking about a hiring event
drive-through style
reporting live in downtown hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys